(lively music)
- So we always like to close out
with something fun and
uplifting, trending on social.
This is, What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
When you think of male calendar models,
these guys may not be the
vision you have in your mind.
Or maybe they are.
These are some of the men
(audience laughing)
of the 2023 Barbecue Boy
Toys Dad Bod Calendar.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] Wooh!
- They're mainly all
Veterans helping raise
tens of thousands of
dollars for fellow Veterans
by posing, scantily clad,
alongside their favorite meats and sauces,
which is the greatest idea ever.
(audience laughing)
Can we look at Mr. December for a moment?
Let's just hang out with it.
I love it!
It's amazing.
We have the creator of the
Dad Bod Calendar on the line
watching on NBC Chicago at Three.
What's up, Steve!
(audience cheering)
- What's up, Kelly?
- Oh my gosh, I love this!
So, how did you come up with this idea?
- So, I do barbecue competitions.
And then from the barbecue competitions,
people were inquiring
about where they could buy
my barbecue sauce.
Just from there, I figured
I might as well go ahead
and start a little side gig
and sell barbecue sauce.
And so I started a
company called Veterans Q
Barbecue Sauces and Rubs.
And the name Veterans Q comes
out because I'm a Veteran,
and what I do that's
different is I donate 50%
of my profits back to
Veteran organizations
that are credible.
- That's so cool.
- And how the calendar came about is,
I was trying to figure
out why would someone
buy my barbecue sauce over something else,
or something else that
they see in the store.
So, trying to figure
out how to do marketing,
and maybe get something to go viral.
And we're just sitting
around, and we started
discussing that Dad Bods were a big deal
about five years ago.
So, we figured why not
do a Dad Bod Calendar,
but do it kind of sexy, and
a little funny and silly,
and have guys with Dad Bods
pose in their underwear
and doing Boudoir style poses.
So we did a calendar, like
I said, for five years now,
and we raised about $50,000
or so, a little more.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh man.
I will never look at the
American flag the same
from that front pose.
It's incredible.
So, thank you so much, Steve.
This is cool.
I mean, it's very
humorous what's happening.
But also, it's very cool.
Like you said, all these organizations
are benefiting from it.
It's a really remarkable
thing that you're doing.
The profits that you're sending
to these organizations,
I can imagine, are so
helpful and beneficial.
So, thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
I'm liking your post right now.
- Thanks.
Keep that up.
- Thank you,
Barbecue Boy Toys, all over the World.
That's not all, though.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the go to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show",
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
and naked sometimes, just like you.
So, they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars
to help you support more veterans.
(audience cheering)
- Awesome.
Thank you so much, that's awesome.
- Absolutely!
Thank you so much, Steven!
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Nick Jonas, Wendy Raquel
Robinson, and Kyle Richards.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.